how do you feel when you see
you know
somebody incredibly wealthy like jon
stewart somebody i'm a fan of as a
comedian do a segment on the problem
with freedom or you see
incredibly well-fed wealthy ivy league
students championing socialism and
telling people to give up their freedom
of speech
you know you're coming from a place of
of of
like you said before this isn't reading
philosophy you're not reading das
capital you've lived it so now you see
these people and do you pity them do you
say they just don't know what they know
or or what what are what are your
thoughts on on this moment
it it's hard to see america at this
moment because we're so divided in our
ideals and uh the greatest country
you know um
i mean any patriot loves our country
right we all love our country
um yeah it's it hurts me divided but the
thing that i realize is this after the
war was um
you have to know what you can change and
what you can't and you have to put you
have to put focus on what you can change
and what you cannot
so if america is so divided i as a
patriot as i as an american as a refugee
that made it into this country
and you you tell me man what other
country can you come here as a refugee
and be who you are
to be an entrepreneur and to be who you
are to be this leader in america when
you came from absolutely nothing
you know i slept on the dirt floor
rats
in the jungle and here i am this
entrepreneur now a leader in america
where else
can a system a country allow you to do
something like that so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]